you were part of the british national
party for a while i think about 10 years
ago
and you left because you thought they
were going too far
right you thought they were becoming
racist and that caused you to leave
correct um no so so what happened was
that that was when when i spoke about
the beslem school massacre
which when i was 21 i started looking
online
to find who's talking about these things
and there was only one group talking
about and they were called the british
national party
i joined the british national party on
the 12 month they had a meeting so i
went along to the meeting
and i joined in that meeting in my
hometown
they then set up a second meeting where
we were going to bring our friends
when i turned up with my friends to the
second meeting they said he can't come
in
he can't come in it was the black lads
these blacks are english lads yeah
they're my best friends
so they said they can't come in so i
said what do you mean they can't come in
and they say
non non-white people can't join the
british national party
now i was 21 years old never involved in
politics never had an interest in
politics i did i didn't realize then
that the leader of this organization is
named nick griffin
i didn't realize he was a holocaust
denier i didn't realize that um
i didn't realize that he used to be
leader of a national front an artsy
organisation
and so from that which there was a
leaked membership list which is how
people know i was a member
but i didn't rejoin the next three years
that was my flirtation with the british
national party was done
i then in 2009
like five years later i set up the
english defense league
i set that up based on my own principles
which were
anyone can join we actually went on to
have
a seek division a lesbian and gay
division a jewish division
um anyone that's affected by these
problems because
i've got i've grown up in a town where i
don't care about other cultures i don't
care about
i don't care if you're gay i don't care
if you're straight
none of that bothers me my problem
is with this radical this radical
ideology which is going to cause us all
serious problems so
but i then did leave the english defense
league as well yes i left in 2013.
i left because i found that a lot of my
time the majority of my time actually
was not
spend trying to tackle the issues it was
spent trying to keep
backward inbred far-right nazis out of
the movement
right so that's a really interesting
point and i think it sort of illuminates
your story a lot so to be clear
you left one party because they didn't
want black people
basically in their party and then when
you started the edl
where you had plenty of people from all
walks of life joining you you ended up
leaving that too because it went too far
right
so when people paint you as this ultra
right nationalist
whether they agree with all the other
stuff you're saying or not that just
it just isn't true from any estimation
that i can see
anyone anyone can spend five minutes on
google you can go to these ultra right
wing
nazi nationalist organizations and see
what they think of me
i get just as many death threats from
them i'm known as
i'm known as the real far right see what
happens is i get called far right
the real far right in the uk i'm a
zionist stooge
um that that's what i'm known as from
the real firearm
of course of course yeah of course so
real quick though on when you left
the edl that was facilitated by quilliam
which is majid nuaz's organization
that's trying to foster coexistence i've
had majid on i
hugely admire him can you just real
quick
explain how he helped facilitate you uh
getting out
i was leaving i was leaving the
organization anyway so i was leaving i
made the decision i was leaving
i then met majid noes um i'd known of
the
their organization some of the work
they'd done anyway um
if i'm honest it benefited me and it
benefited him
at that time and that's just me being
completely honest i then
i then spent some time with quilliam um
who are
seen as reformist muslims what what i
realized then was that
many of them are if they're honest are
apostates
um they don't follow the teachings of
islam which is why they're
able to say what they do but then
because of that
so they're softening the blow so to
speak they're not coming out right and
saying we don't believe in this they're
saying we're trying to reform it just
because that's a little more palatable
sort of
yeah but then they're targeted they're
actually hated more than me
they're actually hated more than me by
muslims
and then the more time i spend look i i
met
majid osama hassan osama hassan i'd
still say is one of the most sincere and
decent men i've met
in my life but they they're not being
entirely honest with the public
about where we're at um i'd done some
training in there
and i was taught that when we talk about
islamists so
the acceptable word now is that we're
against islamists we're against islamism
yeah
which if so then what they said is
islamist ideology and
they wrote a graph and drew this chart
it was punishment for adultery
uh punishment for homosexuality all the
all the backward ideas that come out of
it
but and and they said that 90 of mosques
in the uk
are propagating this not 90 of the
muslims in the mosque
yeah but 90 of the mosque because of
who's funding and controlling them and
the hierarchy in the teachers and the
imams
ninety percent of whom can't speak
english either they're ninety percent of
the
most
propagandist ideology and they had they
had islamist ideology under false islam
and then they had true islam which they
said ten percent were but i said i have
a huge problem with this
because if 90 are propagating this in
the uk
that's true islam i get what you're
trying to do and i wish you
i wish you every success in trying to
change this
but we've had 1400 years of history that
shows it hasn't changed
you're fighting a battle now where and i
asked them when the last time i saw
osama
san i said how many people have you
converted to your liberal form of islam
this week
because whilst you've been doing that
radical extremists in prisons across
this country and our schools across this
country
have probably converted thousands yeah
and i want to get to the prison part in
a little bit because you've had some
completely insane experiences in prison
but just to wrap this part up
the interesting piece here is that
although you're not working with majid
now
you guys in your own way you're both
apostates to your community he's
considered you know i see all the
horrible things that people
call him porch monkey and terrible
things coming out of
the the muslim community saying about
him and coming from white people on the
left
which they'd be considered racist if
they said it about about a black person
of course
but in a way you both are now sort of
outcasts
and that kind of brings you together
which to me that's where the real
conversation is whether you work with
him or kill him ever again
that's that's the the lane that this has
to go down
the conversation is there but um this
isn't a time for conversation
it's like it's if we could rely on
muslims to solve this problem
if i i'm at the opinion now we can't
unfortunately
i think i spent two years floating there
with different groups and talking to
every moderate muslim i'm introduced to
just tomorrow night in the uk there's a
bbc radio 4 program and i went last week
because we're going and i traveled
around meeting muslim leaders again
and when i met this a counter extremism
counter-terrorism
hailed as the most moderate of muslims
you can get
when i sat down with him i said will you
please condemn punishment for apostasy
in the islamic states whether that be in
saudi arabia just anywhere in the world
please condemn it
you wouldn't do it i said you can't even
condemn that someone has the freedom to
think
you can't even do that he goes we're not
there i said that's not hard it's not
difficult either you want people to be
punished for thinking a different way or
you don't
and this is another muslim that's hailed
as the most moderate and to be honest
if i can't say i've met one other than
imaginary
other than some of the muslims in
quilliam other than that all the
all the muslims i've met and i've i've
pushed them on questions
i found out that once i've scratched
underneath the surface actually they
hold some quite apparent views
they do yeah so and if it was time for
if muslims could solve this problem then
the combined military force surrounding
50 to 100
000 isis soldiers or isis millions is up
to five million muslims
um combined military force and that
they've done nothing and and they're not
going to
so we we have we have to do things now
we have to enforce laws we have to push
agendas that are going to make sure that
we're secure and then make sure that we
we
are not just secure but stable in the
future and we can't rely on muslims to
do
you